let's get down to business and watch
this trailer but before we do that I
wanted to say thank you again to
Skillshare for working with us this week
that was like dream sponsorship do you
know what I'm main skills share in case
you guys don't know their online
learning community for creators across
the board from like art business design
more and just a friendly reminder that
if you use our special link in the
description box you can take advantage
of Skillshare premium which has over
25,000 classes on it you can pretty much
take anyone you want for the next two
months and then after that it's only $10
to continue so head on that's that
description box after this video to see
if you're interested in a free two month
trial with the awesome skill share now
let's watch Eddie Murphy reprises role
as Mushu oh that's oh well
[Music]
that is beautiful
[Music]
we have excellent news the matchmakers
found you an auspicious match it is to
send it ah come in sit down it is what
is best for family time mom yes Brianna
song
quiet
post
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes my judge says you're not doin the
whole disguise thing as those supposed
to maybe that's towards the end of the
movie could be could be those look very
beautiful and very scopic I'm very happy
with this trailer yeah yeah yeah I'm
very happy with it you know what I'm a
little upset that there's no
controversial casting why why are they
all looking asian that's not right
little red dragon voice by the famous
black comedian he's a little
motion-capture with some Eddie Murphy in
there man he's not busy what this is the
director of Whale Rider
yeah and I'm several other dramas well
zookeepers wife I love how it doesn't
feel like a New Zealand finish yeah it
doesn't feel like just some direct
adaptation of the animated movie even in
like tone a lot of shows are the
adaptation is the Animated Classics
yep the live-action version of that this
looks like it's taking itself I'm sure
there'll be a lot of humor of course I
mean it's a Disney film but for the most
part seems like it's taken its course
story with a lot more of a serious and
nuanced feeling like an actual epic tale
with some dramatic weight to back it up
as opposed to just hey remember the
animated movie like this this feels like
it's gonna be doing a lot of different
things with it well yeah and it seems
like they're leaning into the war epic
side of it which you know it's like
we've again doing all these different
reboots of all these different Disney
classics yeah I mean a lot of times it
is neat to see them like faithfully
recreate something but in this context I
totally agree it's it's this looks like
a different step for them in a story
that arguably from its original
adaptation could use a little bit of
readapt ation oh yeah definitely well I
remember when I was younger and hearing
about you know nowadays everything seems
like it's never controversy but when I
was younger I remember move on was
especially met with controversy because
there's a lot of people who thought that
it was actually in a very insulting
movie that it was just making fun of a
lot of stereotypes yeah operating things
and not necessarily living within the
culture it's a better
so I feel like they have to be more
sensitive this time around and actually
have a layer of authenticity for example
in China they're all speaking English
which is how it cooks and then we took
over and they're like nah we gotta do
our own thing now by America he
constructs just a one distracting thing
to me okay everything feels like a lot
more grounded and realistic but they're
all speaking English the irony here this
is gonna be Disney's movie to be Avatar
you know because that Chinese mark is
gonna show the production values I mean
they always look good on these movies
but it did strike me that this looks
like we're gonna get into the
nitty-gritty of battle and I like that
this teaser had the monologue talking
about what great a wife like quality is
she has wall juxtaposing all those
against the visual of her training began
the warrior this movie looks like it'll
have humour but it doesn't look like a
comedy no it's very good the animated
movie is very goofy for some reason I'm
actually really liking the more serious
approach that being said to this musical
number I can't imagine there's musical
numbers how is this kind of movie about
to say where would the music yeah many
don't see from this teaser where a
musical number would just fit yeah you
know not that I can't imagine it but it
doesn't give me any of that from this
you know I really admire about it too is
the tone of it the real sort of quiet
performance that we're getting from the
lead actress excuse me a professor named
wrong Lou yuffie Louie Liu Yu Fei Yue
Liu Yu she's playing along yeah the sort
of like quiet body language performance
that is communicating here it's cool to
get an actress who you can communicate
so much just through the eyes but every
time you cut to her I'm like I feel for
this woman yeah yeah totally and I think
that's appropriate to because Mulan like
now that I'm an expert on the the
original original story but it seems
like kind of an isolated position to be
coming from it's like you shouldn't be
here already you're posing yet Roos
going on and you're in like the thick of
risking your life
I don't like a neighboring clan or
whatever so yeah I got to imagine that
there would be a lot riding on her
shoulders and a lot for her performance
- yeah embody through that so I'm
looking forward to it you know I've seen
her actually a couple times I didn't
even realize like in stuff like the
Forbidden Kingdom and things like that
it'll be nice to see her actually get to
take the center stage and actually kick
some ass as I hope no she doesn't kick
any ass just finds a husband gets
married contemplating going and taking
your dad's place then she's like go to
war but there's other characters in here
that I mean gently supposed to be the
Emperor right see Forbidden Kingdom
reunited happening and Donnie Yen was
buying a new commander a new character
entirely there's a character supposed to
be replacing li Shang yeah the original
romantic interest no longer but they got
a guy from New Zealand I don't know if
the guys actually like Asian and not
even Maori or any but I'm here why
hearing so much about how they're
totally taken out like main characters
yeah putting in completely different
characters to support the narrative they
want to tell here and then just looking
at this trailer I'm excited for this
matter because because this looks like
this step in the direction of what a lot
of us say about the adaptation movies of
the Disney films and there's you have
the shot of like a bird at one point
there was a rumor that Mushu might be
replaced by a Phoenix character play by
sophie turner sophie turner is gonna
play it and so is famke janssen yeah
everybody I don't know if this bird shot
was a hint at totus is the new moo shu
character either way this this actually
made me a lot happier than I anticipated
yeah and I do love the animation it's
titled it's like controversy element
sighs I do love it I think it's a really
funny movie and we are we were children
and we didn't know better
was great yeah didn't recognize it as a
problematic faith and identifying his
Asian I was like this is pretty cool and
I wasn't aware of how insensitive so I
was like this is good I'm overseeing I
really hope the actions gonna be great
too the only thing that really detracts
from this trailer for me is just way too
much feminism you know yeah yeah it's
like most of this trailer she looks like
a girl when she's supposed to be a man
supposed to be trying to look like a
deer I'm supposed to forget all about
her original assigned gender well guys
thanks for watching you sat for the new
Mulan trailer make sure to subscribe the
real rejects click that notification
bell so you get notified whenever we
have a video up and go ahead and check
us out on patreon as well I want to get
a patron today shout out to a woman
named Anissa Oliver she was telling me
recently that she has a boyfriend
they've been out for quite some time
handsome devil named Tyler ooh I'm gonna
keep this really age-appropriate because
you know there's a move-on trailer but I
did want to give you some advice take a
page out of the Mulan story what really
makes a guy excited is when you dress up
like a guy so and best him in battle as
my tidbit of advice yeah fight him and
watch where your relationship goes oh
yeah dominations way to climb is up